. Donald Trump's attorney general, William
Barr, is now claiming that the pepper spray
used to clear the path from the White House
to St. John's Church is, quote, not a chemical
irritant.
This is the latest version, the latest defense
of the now seven day old photo op that Donald
Trump did, which ended, remember, with Donald
Trump awkwardly holding a Bible in front of
St. John's Church last Monday.
We had video for you from last week of protesters
clearly being gassed and dispersed with horses.
You can see the gas rising as protesters flee.
So the first statement the White House put
out was no tear gas was used, seemed like
an obvious lie.
And indeed, eventually a statement was put
out, I believe, by the Park Service saying
we were wrong when we said it was incorrect
to say that tear gas was not used.
That was not true.
So then William Barr, who's a completely sinister
character in this entire Greek tragedy of
the Trump administration, Trump's attorney
general, a general, defended the use of what
they used by saying, listen, they were warned
multiple times before we started deploying
the crowd control elements like gas.
And we'll pick it up there.
Here's William Barr saying, once police met
resistance from protesters, yes, it was appropriate
to use tear gas to clear a path for Donald
Trump.
Take a look.
Where appropriate is that resistance?
Yes.
They announced three times they didn't move.
By the way, there was no tear gas used.
The tear gas was used Sunday when they had
to clear a street to allow the fire department
to come in safe St. John's Church.
That's when tear gas was used.
Chemical irritants, the piano.
There were not Samisoni or tense.
Pepper spray is not a chemical.
It's a chemical pepper spray.
You're saying it was used pepper balls and
you believe that's appropriate.
So Barr says everything was justified.
Tear gas was not used and pepper spray balls
are not a chemical irritant.
So let's go through these claims one by one.
First, tear gas wasn't used.
Local reporters went through the area after
this fiasco and they collected used canisters
of s.m speed, heat, CBS and s.m scat shell.
Oh, see, these are two types of tear gas.
Now, is it possible that that was tear gas
leftover from the previous day, as William
Barr is claiming that the previous day, Sunday,
not Monday, they used tear gas because it's
hypothetically possible?
Doesn't seem hugely likely.
So that part Barr saying tear gas wasn't used.
Appears to be a lie.
Then we get into the semantic thing.
Tear gas versus pepper spray.
They are both chemical irritants.
Each uses a different irritant.
Pepper spray uses capsicum, which comes from
the active compound in hot peppers.
Tear gas is a halogen compound that is powder
like at room temperature.
So in the most technical sense, these are
two different things.
But the CDC classifies pepper spray as a form
of teargas.
So it becomes merely a semantic argument.
Now, lastly, Barr says pepper spray is not
a chemical irritant.
Well, it is an irritant.
This issue of chemical is that the chemical
is one that exists in food as well.
It's a highly concentrated version of the
irritant in peppers.
So what Barr maybe is leaning on is that it's
a natural element rather than a lab made chemical.
But when you're talking about hot peppers
and going through a process where you extract
the irritant from the peppers concentrated
into a pepper spray, the fact that it's, quote,
naturally occurring seems irrelevant.
And William Barr, you know, he seems to be
suggesting that this is no different than
tossing some hollow pancho's at protesters.
This is a highly concentrated, very powerful
irritant that once again, the CDC classifies
as a form of tear gas.
So it's gaslighting and it's deception all
around.
And William Barr, a horribly sinister figure
in the Trump administration, once again, The
David Pakman Show David Pakman Darkon.